i also wanted to ask you about working
with zack snyder
specifically because one of the things i
admire about him most as a filmmaker
is his kind of next level visuals so can
you feel that
from the actor perspective that he is
just kind of you know
like framing a beautiful shot around you
wow i didn't i didn't i wasn't
aware of the stuff around me actually
now i'm thinking about it
and it's interesting because
he's very personable and very like we
had some re
i wasn't on that set very long but we
had some really good conversations
he's a good person and like
he gave me some good advice but i really
felt like it was
about the character actually i didn't
feel the whole scope of it at all
it was very and i think that helped with
the nerves because he would give me like
acting notes he wouldn't say like oh
you're
it looks like this remember to do this
you need to be
you need to match the set the setting or
whatever i actually don't didn't feel
that actually at all
and that really is a credit to him
because sometimes you have directors who
make you fit into their
like what they have in their mind and
they're only they only care about the
shot i i don't
and he gave us time there was a scene
with holly hunter and we had
time to work it out like i was like wow
i have
i really thought this was going to be
maybe an hour shooting and we
really worked out all the ins and outs
of the character
and where where we've been where we're
going like before we even blocked the
scene
we were on it for like an hour and a
half two hours i was like wow i just
you gave us time it wasn't about
i'm sure i mean it obviously was because
that's what you see too like it
obviously was about the shock but it
wasn't
i didn't feel that from him i felt i
felt guided
through it definitely
[Music]
[Applause]